Let's add one more feature
of romance verbs to persons,
tenses and aspects.
It's called mood.
So far the verbs we've met
gave us information about
who performed an action and
when they were all matter of fact
about it, kind of tasks for you,
seeing fantastic for you
sang that kind of thing.
We might even say that they all indicate
who does what there in the indicative
mood plain statement. Send
questions, have indicative verbs,
whatever the tents, contacting
Latino, Qantas in Latino,
such verbs ask for or provide
information in a vanilla way.
Did this happen? Yes, that
happened. Is it? Yes, it is.
These kinds of statements. It's account
for so much of what we say in right,
including most of my narration.
What if the mood isn't so indicative?
Latin and romance verbs also mark
actions as possibly contrary to fact.
We're not necessarily the case.
This is useful when you want hope,
fear, doubt, need or recommending action.
Continuing with my apparent
fondness for the verb Cantata,
compare one indicative form can Thomas
to a subjunctive what containers as in
sped at and teams she hopes that we sing.
It's a matter of fact that she does hope.
So that's in the indicative but
we may or may not actually sing.
So this second for this
and the subjunctive,
I slid a little word quoting there.
It's the word for that in Latin and it
becomes something like gay in nearly
every romance language we use k to connect
the subjunctive or to the verb that
triggers the subjunctive as
in hope that want that need,
that recommend that and so on.
So we did quote is
followed by an indicative
but spirit quote by a subjunctive
notice the thematic vowel,
it switches.
This is a key feature that distinguishes
indicatives and subjunctives.
That's present tense subjunctive stuff.
We can also use a past
subjunctive this past door.
Imperfect subjunctive is especially
useful in hypothetical's.
I beer in languages also developed a
future subjunctive for uncertain future
actions like when I will
sing or if I will sing,
which remains in Portuguese but
not Spanish window can perish.
Western romance languages have conditional
endings that work a lot like the
future indicative ending,
step attached.
The verb for have to the
end of an infinitive.
These are fractions.
Someone would do.
The imperfect of have is
used in France and Iberia.
Hmm.
The predicate of have is used in Italy.
Yeah.
Other languages including Romanian
and Sardinian built phrases or use the
imperfect indicative to get
the same conditional meaning.
Yeah.
Imperatives issue a command. The
basic idea is simple. Take the verb,
add the thematic.
Val got into
some common verbs. Are you
thinking shorter? Deek, Tara?
Also plural,
forms for ordering around
a group of people via data.
A negative command uses this
subjunctive in Iberia. No one contests.
The infinitive is used in Italy,
northern Canada,
in languages that use third person forms
to address you politely like contact
for both sings and you sir or Madam Sing.
The subjunctive comes back into play
for both positive and negative commands.
Contact
content,
person number, tense aspect, mood.
You now all the basic features of romance,
verb endings.
Next time it's on to helping verbs.
Notably [inaudible] to
have an aesthetic to be.